- Over your fears, nobody's
fucking opinion named
Johnnypants49 who says
"you're ugly", should stop
you from fucking winning your life.
(applauding)
It's funny, Vayner Media
is super interesting to me.
I'm building Vayner Media the way I was
raised and the way, which I
think I really believe this,
I think you over coddle and
over love up front.
You just establish it.
It's just love.
And you're good, almost
like delirium like blind
like you're the best.
And then around six, seven,
eight, you start chipping away
at it and start saying
like, "No you're not the
"best basketball player," like you're not
like, and start creating
some realistic part.
But when you establish
like a foundation of
who you are, and what my
mom did was, she over-spent
her time conversating about what I
was great at, she made
me have consequences for
what I didn't, and away we went.
- Hello, how are you?
- Whattup vlog?
Good morning Houston, Texas.
H-Town mother fuckers!
Uh, got a speech here.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
(applauding)
- I came here today, to inspire you to go
spend 50 hours learning through reading
books, watching videos, downloading
PDF's; I don't know how you learn.
I came here today to inspire all of you to
spend 50 more hours, whether you know this
like Steve, but he should know more.
If I needed to know more,
he needs to know more.
Or you've completely dismissed this,
because you're fucking
Summer and you think
you can beat this, this
is a fucking tidal wave!
Do you know what happens when you stand
up to a tidal wave?
I'm finding a surfboard and
riding it to the sunset,
you think your tough
and you're gonna get fucking annihilated.
Please go put in the 50
hours of work of learning,
please download every
fucking one of these apps,
start tasting them and learning it.
Get over your fears.
Nobody's fucking opinion named
Johnnypants49 who says
"you're ugly", should stop
you from fucking winning your life.
(cheering)
I have a bunch of business calls and then
off to Super Bowl.
Tonight, we have our,
our party which is the
Entrepreneur Magazine
and Vayner Sports party
of the top entrepreneurial athletes.
For a lot of people here, you've willed
this into success; like a lot more than
you'd ever really imagine.
Like, hard work is an
unbelievable variable.
You know I get, I'm getting shit on quite
a bit right-and I've been very careful
in clarifying over the
last 24 months, depending
on how long you've been
following me of like
no, no I sleep six, seven
hours, but I'm more focused on
the other 18, because it's true!
Like I sleep, it's just that
I'm on fire because I'm happy.
(dramatic music)
I'm from fucking Belarus, baby!
Whattup Target?
So we're going into the
party here, in Minnesota.
Vayner Sports party with
Entrepreneur Magazine.
Uh, really, really excited
about it, it should
be really great.
We're very focused on the
best entrepreneurial athletes;
we're giving away some awards, doing
a fireside chat, looking forward to it.
- [Man] Are you excited about
your first Super Bowl party?
- Yeah, this is like super
interesting, right, like
passion uh, I've fallen
in love with the industry.
I mean, when I see the
Entrepreneur logo and you know,
it's one of those things when you
grow up from humble
beginnings and you have
passions; if you would
have shown me this picture
of us two, those two
logos, you know I would
have been like, "What?"
You know, and so it's super,
uh, it's super humbling.
(dramatic music)
You know, I think it's a
million variables, but most
of all, I respect where the attention is.
- So you need to tell me, how you as
entrepreneurs, are going to elevate the
vibration of the collector
of your community?
- For me, uh, I've penetrated
youth culture because
I understand Snapchat,
and Instagram, and YouTube
and all those things way
better than any person
in this room.
(laughs)
- Or in the world.
- And what I've done, is
I've gotten in very early
and I'm pushing very tried and true
work ethic, kindness, gratitude, patience.
And watching 15, you know
getting DM's from kids
who are like, "Yo just
6 months ago I'm just
"laying in my bed doing
drugs all day listen to
"this, that, and the other
thing and you've, you
"got into my stream, you got me looking at
"different shit and this
is where my life's at."
The way I'm looking to
elevate is I'm looking
into getting in real early
and I'm trying to, through
sheer force, build
popularity so that kindness
and gratitude and empathy
become cool things, instead
of putting cash to your
fucking ear or having
ice on your fucking wrist.
(applauding)
Yo, whattup Batman asked
me to close it out.
This is my favorite meme!
Vader Sports party went
well, we're going to Tao, um,
we can't show that, and so
uh we're wrapping it up.
Big day tomorrow, reading
the audio, I came to
Super Bowl weekend to read
my fucking audio book so
I can get it out sooner for you fuckers.
So, I got you!
I got you!
And special guest in the back,
Patrick show em, show 'em!
There he is!
There's no fucking light, who's got light?
Show this man!
Tell him he's got it!
Uh, uh, uh!
The team baby let's go,
K-Swiss for life baby!
K-Swiss for life!
(dramatic music)